WOJTEK KALICINSKI:
I'm Wojtek Kalicinski.
This is Android Tool Time.
And let's talk a bit about
the Espresso Test Recorder
and how it can help with
adding UI tests to your app.
[ALARM RINGING]
But first, a short
explanation for those
unfamiliar with Espresso.
Espresso is a testing
framework designed
to provide a fluent API for
writing concise and reliable UI
tests.
However, it is often
the case that developers
are reluctant to add
UI tests to their apps
or simply don't have time
to learn the framework.
This is where the Espresso
Test Recorder comes in.
It lets you create
and add UI tests
to an existing app in
an interactive way.
You might have previously
seen the beta version
of this feature, but
in Android Studio 2.3
we are promoting it to stable
with a few enhancements.
To get started with
the Test Recorder click
on Record Espresso Test
under the Run menu.
The device selection
dialog pops up.
And after you make your
choice, the Test Recorder
runs your app in debug mode.
Simply progress
through your app's UI
as a regular user would
by clicking buttons,
swiping, and typing
into input fields,
and all those actions will
appear in the Test Recorder
window.
You can also click here
to add an assertion
to your test at any
time during recording,
which will trigger the
Test Recorder to dump
the current view hierarchy.
To select the view you
want to assert on, click
on the screenshot that
appears in the recorder window
and choose between the
assertion type from view
exists, doesn't exist, or check
that it contains the specified
text.
When you've finished
recording your test,
the test record generates
the equivalent test code
to run your actions
and assertions
and puts it in a new file in
your projects instrumentation
test folder.
It also checks if
your build file
contains the required
Espresso dependencies and adds
those if needed.
When you look at the source
file that the Espresso Test
Recorder created, you will
see that it's perfectly normal
human-readable code.
So if you need to further
customize your tests
or alter them when
your app changes,
you can simply open
the file again and make
the alterations you need.
As you can see, the
Espresso Test Recorder
is very simple to
use, but it does
come with some limitations.
As of Android Studio 2.3, only
a few most common assertions
are available through
the recorder UI.
See, if you need anything
more complicated than that,
you will need to edit the
generated code by hand.
Also, at this stage, the Test
Recorder cannot handle all
situations where additional
synchronization is needed
to deal with delays and async
operations in your apps.
I highly recommend getting
familiar with the Espresso
idling resource
API and using that
in your tests to signal when a
long-running operation happens.
For advanced users who want
to tweak some aspects of test
cogeneration, there
is a settings page
for the Test Recorder in
Android Studio Preferences.
Here you can change the
maximum view hierarchy depth
that will be used for
view identification
and if app data should
be cleared every time you
record a new test.
The Espresso Test
Recorder is a great way
to start adding
tests to your app,
whether you want
to learn Espresso
by examining the
generated code or simply
to quickly build a Test Suite
which you can customize later.
We look forward to your
feedback on our social channels,
and happy testing.
Thanks for watching.
And for more Android
Studio videos, click here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]